you know there there are bands in
certain parts of this country now on
critical race theory in schools that's
great i love that i think we got to kick
it out of schools there's three views on
this there's the leftist view which is
indoctrinate kids into critical race
theory there's the libertarian view
which is you know just do whatever and
do whatever you want and it's kind of up
to you and i don't want to impose my
views on you and it's a free marketplace
of ideas right and then there's the
conservative view which is no this stuff
is poison it undermines students
education kick it out and fire the
teachers who push it
so there's an iowa teacher
who is very frustrated by the crt ban
and now she's bragging about the ways
that she circumvents it
i said but we also need to take a look
at hf-802 and i literally put the law in
front of them gave them access to it
with a link and i said and i need to
just let you know there are now concepts
that is illegal for me to teach you
about
according to the state of iowa and we
went through um they used to be called
defined concept or divisive concepts now
they're called defined concepts in our
law um so i went through those ten
defined concepts with them um so that
they could see what the law was and they
immediately by the time i think we're on
the second or third one they're like but
is it illegal for me to ask questions
can i i was like
this is only for me you can ask as many
questions as you like and then i took
him to the part of the law that said um
this law doesn't prohibit me from
answering questions
i said so if there's any question that
you have about these defined concepts
you can ask them
and then i can answer them
so i said so let's just take another
minute
what questions do you have that you want
me to build this course around and take
some time to answer and the questions
after going through hf 802 were so much
more pointed like one of them straight
up was a sticky note that says is the
united states systemically racist
and i was like well that would be a
fascinating conversation that now we can
have because you've asked
well wow isn't she clever isn't she's so
clever she's gonna because the the law
like the
the people let me just i'll take you
through she probably hasn't seen
schoolhouse rock in a while the people
voted for their representatives and the
people fund the government including the
public schools and pay that woman's
salary and then the people said you know
we don't want you teaching our kids that
white people are horrible and racist and
irredeemable we don't we don't think
that's good we don't think it's true and
we don't think it's good to teach a kid
that and we think you're a psycho and we
don't want you doing that so they pass a
law through their
constitutional order
and then this teacher says thank you
thank you for that salary that's good
thank you for your that paycheck i'm
gonna put that over here
and you know i love our democracy our
democracy is so great and now i'm gonna
completely disregard the law
and i'm going to continue to teach kids
that white people are evil and america's
a terrible place she just admits it
there she goes is america systemically
racist well
you know i'm the law says i'm not
allowed to tell you that it is but
that's an interesting question
and since you asked since i impelled you
to ask that question no i'm going to
tell you it's terrible america's
terrible and white people are evil and
everything's and you're the worst
and we all need to become like haiti and
that's why we need to let the hate all
the haitians into america is that am i
following that and you've got to mask up
unless you're feeling the spirit if you
are a democrat mayor or a hollywood
celebrity but not you because you the
people are evil and i don't care what
you tell me to do and i don't care what
laws you pass
i am not beholden to your laws
would you know an oligarchy if you saw
one i'm so glad you enjoyed that clip
if you like that oh baby the best is yet
to come you got to check out the whole
episode you can get that here on youtube
and you can comment and subscribe you
can also get it at apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play head on over there
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe
you will never miss an episode i would
greatly appreciate it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]